so Mike you get your first signing bonus  what you do so in my mind I'm gonna get  three million dollars so you know I talk  about my hunts my my mom my sister's got  everybody in the HUD homes like like  this the plate I'd seen I'm gonna give  you fifty thousand and you know a nice  GMC truck enjoy someone give you a  hundred thousand and mom was a given you  know she was receivers of jewels so she  was gonna get without but she won't get  the check  I saw opening up when I look at it and I  just look at my mom and she looking like  she thought it was a blank check if she  thought it was a joke away being punked  the song it's ex hit one point nine  million dollars I'm like oh oh mom we  got a problem  houston we got a problem for sure they  took them without that GSE also you see  turn into like a Camaro  I was tougher than going to prison  stayed up a lot of money I wanted to  kick myself an ass for her